let's give it up for the winners of the
prestigious teacher of the year award
from washington d.c
[Applause]
oh my gosh
[Applause]
oh my gosh
grandis would you be so kind as to tell
us about these looks absolutely so drew
you know that every time i come here i
have on a blazer that is my thing and so
i love this blazer on her we just talked
to some of the teachers a second ago
about how a blazer really almost makes
you feel like you have an armor
it makes you feel so powerful and
pairing this with like a mini skirt and
these loafers just kind of make sure
that it's you know the look is totally
complete
and then a scarf can change any look so
without the scarves you'd have on a
denim shirt and these beautiful pink
pants but the scarf really ties it all
together nicely with that print so the
prints as you know are so huge prints
are always great for the springtime and
this print looks absolutely beautiful on
her you guys look so stunning i mean
and
finally um i would love to introduce a
husband and wife teacher duo
um they wanted a little refresh
so here is jersey's teacher of the year
angel santiago come on out
[Applause]
[Music]
how do you feel and don't look that way
because your wife is there and we're
revealing her as a surprise how do you
feel i feel great i mean this outfit's
me i love it i feel awesome i feel great
in this outfit okay and um are you ready
to see your wife absolutely been waiting
all day please welcome courtney
[Applause]
may i ask when you met were you both
teachers
we were yeah i think we were yeah we
both started the same year so you're
like oh my god i'm a teacher oh my god
you're a teacher and
i i helped him yeah actually i was a
musician so i met her at a you know at a
at one of our shows and
uh and then you're like oh my god i'm
gonna become a teacher yeah yeah exactly
yeah
um i um can you just tell me really
quickly one thing you admire about each
other's teaching
i think for my wife she she deals with a
population the specialized population
and uh you know she she puts her heart
and soul she treats her those kids like
if they're her own and she's a fantastic
mother so uh it shows in her classroom
as well
[Applause]
yes with angel i mean sometimes it
drives me crazy but his dedication to
his students um his craft obviously
teacher of the year is like the highest
accolade ever so super proud of him his
dedication is unmatched so thank you so
much for this opportunity it was great
day together
everybody has been asking me what i'm
doing after the show
um but chris what did you do with the
hair your hair is stunning you know it
was we've done lots throughout the
process of lightening hair we've cut
hair we've added shape and texture a lot
of it was honestly just about the
quality of the hair though a lot of
women struggle these days we're keeping
a good quality of hair just because
we're constantly changing it and
evolving it whether the hair is colour
treated whether your hair straight curly
texturized whatever it is it's about
getting a great finish to the hair and
that's kind of i guess what i became
known for as as what i do with hair
whatever it is it has that quality
and now a lot of that is just about
styling and using products to actually
you know make your hair look much better
without a lot of work so obviously
everyone leaves today with the dream
coat but that's my go-to product it
transforms the texture of hair on all
heads of hair curly straight whatever it
is and gives you that really kind of you
know more looks finish you you saw when
we walked out it was kind of bouncy and
glossy and you feel like you just want
to swing it around a lot of that is just
about transforming the hair with
products and quite often we forget about
that you know so i think it's really
important to have the tools to recreate
these looks at home as well it's true i
always forget products
[Applause]
charlotte what else did you do
well i just want to show you this
because this is my
multi-miracle this is a multi-glow and
when you put this on top of the
cheekbone i don't know if you can see
that there in the camera but how that
just gives you that dream sheen
glass-like glow skin that's like smooths
out any pores any fine lines because
it's a new technology and you put it
down the center of the nose a little bit
on the top of the lip
and that just gives you that lifts your
cheekbones i feel like it also grabs
that light it does it and throws it on
your face and says look at me yes
yes
i cannot thank you enough i mean the one
and only charlotte tilbury the
magnanimous brandess daniel and chris
appleton our dear friend and hair
stylist extraordinaire and most
importantly our 25 incredible
game-changing teachers
i also want to thank chill house
for doing the nails and finally a huge
thank you to talbot's a company i've
recently had the pleasure of working
with and they provided all the clothes
today and they're giving 150 gift
certificate to all the teachers
[Applause]
thanks everybody
thanks so much
[Music]